he also wants to invoke something called
the Insurrection act which will allow
him to use US military force against
American civilians at home
misinformation specialist from the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC Rachel mattow went on stevenh
kar's quote unquote comedy show last
night and you're not going to believe
who she compared Trump to and did very
well against it that is the hopeful
nature of this book which I want to get
into in just a moment but first I want
to ask you about what's been happening
recently on on Veterans Day on a
Veterans Day speech Trump called the
left Vermin and
fascists and you know a two or thing
about fascism in this book why do you
think he's leaning in to these
comparisons yeah I think it's important
that it very clearly wasn't an adlib
this wasn't something that uh he riffed
on it was seemed to have been in his
teleprompter Trump did that at the same
time that we've had these leaks kind of
official leaks from his campaign that he
wants to build camps for millions of
people um that he wants to professional
camps though professional looking I like
the no Crocs element just classes it up
a lot but camps for millions of people
and Americans he also wants to invoke
something called the Insurrection act
which will allow him to use US military
force against American civilians at home
and he says he's going to invoke that on
day one which would give him from that
day forward the ability to use the Army
against us at home um so doing floating
all of those things at once and calling
his opponents Vermin he's deliberately
inviting the criticism that he is
behaving like a Hitler or musolini style
fascist there's so much there so first
off you know just quickly on the word
vermin because maybe it is true I think
you could probably make some argument
that maybe someone who wants to be
president who was president shouldn't
call his opponents Vermin it's a little
different when say a pundit or a media
guy makes fun of the other half but I
maybe you could argue something around
that but I at the same time I can make
the counterargument which is you guys
run around calling him Hitler and all
the Republicans white supremacist all
the time so verman or white supremacist
like we could probably go either way on
that uh as far as using the military and
building camps and everything else it's
not against the Americans he's talking
about how to deal with the illegal
immigrants and the people that are here
who are at these rallies who are
radically anti-america and we've
completely lost control of uh again
either you have a country or you don't
but the the broader Point without even
getting into the minua of all of that is
that they are ramping up the Trump is
Hitler thing they have people out on the
streets their base the MSNBC base the
Democrat base the ilhan Omar Hamas
caucus Rashida Talib crew they have
thousands of people in our streets
calling for the genocide of the Jews and
these clowns have the gall to say that
Donald Trump is the next Hitler it's
just completely
insane